au pays des tgv il suffit de monter dans
un ter pour prendre un grand bol d'air
tout commence au petit arrêt de la
guerre des trois chênes quatre minutes
de train on se gagne 2 heures de marche
à pied et on va voir des paysages
merveilleux et très différents les uns
des autres ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu
faire si on avait fait une boucle tout
simplement à pied
c'est une balade facile 16 km avec moins
de 300 m de dénivelé
comptez 5 heures de marche première
halte à l'étang du malsaucy
la fondatrice d'avallon mais a rendez
vous avec les bernard marck honneur
qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui vous
êtes en train de compter déjà oui mais
je compte les oiseaux qui sont sur le
secteur donc aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de grès bp et puis on commence à voir
arriver tout au fond là-bas il ya un
grand oiseau blanc avec blanc qui est la
grande aigrette mais alors quand le ter
passe on voit certains groupes de
canards colverts qui ne bouge pas qui
est tranquille ils ont d'habitude ce
sont ces missives le que les canards que
vers d'autres il s'envola rapidement
parce que le tf leur fait peur ce sont
ceux qui veulent me dit l'autre
l'histoire avec un grand h nous attend
au sommet du mont salbert lefort
lefebvre est un vestige du passé
militaire de belfort hier il s'agissait
de voir arriver l'ennemi aujourd'hui
c'est un panorama à 360° qui s'offre aux
randonneurs on a des étangs au
magnifique à notre pied la montagne des
vosges qui se découpe dans le ciel de
l'autre côté la forêt noire enfin c'est
juste magnifique
on n'a pas besoin d'aller à l'autre bout
du monde on a tout ce qu'il faut ici de
quoi s'émerveiller vraiment c'est dans
les petits détails que l'on reconnaît
les grandes balades
si les pierres parlent elles nous
raconterait comment les hommes
communiquer autant du télégraphe optique
ça permet de communiquer avec toutes les
autres forts de la ceinture fortifiée de
belfort et jusqu'à besançon avec des
signaux lumineux tout simplement partir
avec en vadrouille ses marchés avec sa
tête et ses jambes sur un territoire qui
prend de l'ampleur en franche comté mais
aussi en lorraine et en alsace
[Musique]